Shh Christmas I'm talking about the many
things monks other things and it's news
this week yeah this podcast is not
brought to you by New Year's that's
going to happen or oh this this podcast
brought to you by bolt and branch
seriously some of the best betting you
can buy ever go to bull and bridge
that's bol el and branch calm and enter
product code Jana Julian for twenty
percent off your entire order of betting
anything like that they have talents
duvets but seriously we're sleeping on
it right now it's it's the best of all
of it this podcast is also also brought
to you by headspace start training your
mind today with headspace guided
meditation in the app store you can get
the app right now for free or go to
headspace comm slash Jenna Julian to get
started and try the trot the 10-day
fruit free meditation program you go ten
days it's a challenge actually they want
you to meditate for ten days straight
and see if you can do it and see how you
like it
and it's all under sent free for the ten
days alright thank you to our sponsors
that's so dope it's really dope that's
so dope that's a new sponsor by the way
headspace we'll talk about that later so
tried it out it's incredible damn dude
really [ __ ] sick anyways anyways man
I could use some headspace right now I
feel you did I mean I try to meditate
sometimes but there's always like a dog
jumping on me it makes it weird not sit
not to hop right into the sponsors but
they actually adore and do that they
account for that to give you ways to
meditate with surrounding noise and
video so you got to try to haven't try
to get a guided meditation for don't
pretty buttoned-up uh so we hope all of
you have a good Christmas Hanukkah
Kwanzaa to pass Kwanzaa I actually don't
really know when it is well whatever led
up to New York I know it's a winter
holiday it's around in there so I hope
you had a good one yeah of it we are
actually recording this in advance right
now just to be transparent we are
leaving to visit
Jenna's family for Christmas so it's
currently before Christmas right number
work yeah recording this a week ahead of
time just so we
can now not have to record from our time
I tell you enough would be possible
right now
it gets weird when you have to do where
we done that once in Vegas yeah yeah it
gets weird but you know what that was
before we were shooting on a good camera
if you're using a terrible camera and
terrible mics think yeah pretty sure
there was definitely the terrible mics
it might have been either that I was
shot on a camera and said hey we'll be
back and no like we literally yeah no we
did yeah
Babli records only reports for like yeah
yeah let it shut off and then pick up
we're good so then I had to go in later
in post and sync up all out it was just
wow
yeah we're in Vegas we're trying to like
crushing it
so we're there for working we're there
for but um yeah we won't be doing that
we want to record beforehand but we had
an idea to talk about for the podcast
today it was kind of we wanted to have
like a discussion sort of thing but
light-hearted and this is what we came
up with you or that well I was thinking
about making it a vlog on my blog
channel um but I said I think it would
be funnier if we did it together
it's not meant to be funny but I think
it would be more interesting if we had
us together you as a guy me as a girl us
as a couple like what your best and
worst worst purchases where in the past
I think it's a it's a good contrast it
is well I feel like we could still do
that as a couple as a separate thing
Oh as a couple the worst things like the
things we've bought collectively bought
right because there have been some yeah
yeah but for this podcast we basically
took some time before coming in here and
and wrote down individually what some of
our best and worst purchases that we
could think of our entire life and I was
like Julien most fair like beautiful
yeah well I mean I can relate to that
side but I didn't I have my own kind of
weird [ __ ] that I yeah bottom fails I
did oh god no I just feel like I was
thinking of a list and I feel like
there's a couple that are just getting
away from me and I'm bothering me anyway
say well I feel like if I made this a
vlog I didn't want it to come across as
like me bashing companies or probably no
it's very easy to get that way with this
or when you talk about good products is
very easy to sound like you're just
promoting
but in all transparency all transparency
and fairness
none of these are sponsored nor do we
like hate any of these no none of these
brands are part of this and are only
sponsors our headspace and both
LaBranche which both of you should check
out right now
headspace you can check out right from
your phone you get the app it's awesome
so how do you want to do this do you
want to waste ones first
okay you want alternate each one yeah
okay all right why don't you go ahead
first all right
the first worst thing that I bought was
not like it wasn't a small purchase it
was expensive at the time yeah it was
like [ __ ] $200 and it was back I want
to say like maybe four years ago or more
when Sephora and everybody was really um
pumping out this temptu airbrush makeup
thing you you've been in Sephora Julian
you like so you love the floral well I'm
just kidding wrong like Julian's prison
because he knows I'm gonna stay in there
in dilly-dally but you know when you
walk in Sephora and they have like all
the products and new products or like
whatever they're really pushing will
have like a display in the front like
they really want you to buy it yes so at
the time it was this temptu airbrush
makeup thing which is you know what an
airbrush it's not like an actual
airbrush it's like a little it's a
little like oh okay
with a little like airbrush thing and
like you can use really good ones like
makeup artists will use good ones where
you like can just dump in like actual
foundation different colors to like mix
something like makeup artists think of a
face off one yes yeah okay so look
meteor yes but it was like
commercialized and you take it home it's
for you yeah but it's for like you know
amateurs that don't know how to mix down
okay and foundation wishes and it's not
nearly as expensive as like a
professional yeah it was like a you know
a mass product for you know just your
average person for sure for sure and it
was called temp 2 it was the first model
because I don't want to talk about the
newer I think there's newer models but
it was the first model and so I of
course like every girl was like oh this
looks [ __ ] dope and to really like
this is it this is Dell
yeah I have to say I bought it and you
buy these little pods so you buy the
foundation in a pod but you can't like
test it on yourself really because you
have to plug it into the airbrush
machine and like whatever so I got a
couple of different shades okay so like
match my foundation I have to say I
[ __ ] loved it for like a month or two
okay
because like you know when you have fake
tan on like you might need a darker
shade like whatever so I was able to
adjust it and it was really nice it
feels like a with a beautiful moist
breeze coming at you and then boom your
foundation is done doesn't click in a
little bronzer so in serious flashes of
course okay but after a little while the
hose like on it the hose are connected
from the box to the sprayer it just
[ __ ] like broke and all the little
pods that I was buying yeah like I would
shake them and they're like oh if it
gets clogged or whatever just wipe
around it and I would wipe around it and
then they would just spit foundation all
over my face like and I'm covered in
like blotches of foundation you can't
make it out that easily well then you
have to go in there and like blend them
so what's the point of that if I have to
go in here and blend it then I'll just
use my liquid or powder cream foundation
why why am i spraying [ __ ] on my face
like a spray paint gun and then it
finally just like sort of disconnected
and I couldn't even get it to work but I
had already bought like all the makeup
pods for it and I'm like well great now
these are just a waste of [ __ ] money
that's really real yeah isn't it yeah it
was so upsetting because I loved it it's
like you don't have to use your brushes
like your hands aren't touching your
face she's such a roller coaster of
emotions you're like you get it like
this is gonna change the game and then
it just completely just backfires and
everything gets [ __ ] well the worst
was that I fell in love with it
no Bennett that's what I'm saying yeah
it wasn't just a bad product from the
get-go it [ __ ] me [ __ ] you man [ __ ]
with your [ __ ] and then but I think what
was even more hurtful than that is that
all of a sudden Sephora just like it
wasn't in there anymore they just said
oh yeah we were wrong but we're not
gonna like tell anyone yo bye this is
gonna change your life
two months later psych everybody buy
this one now and I was like I just got
played yeah
I'm sorry if I sounds like
Thanks it's okay I'm alright I'm sorry
good yeah you need to talk about us
we'll talk about later
yeah I'll be all right yeah um anyway
okay so my first one as you guys know I
grew up playing baseball since I was
very very young all through all
throughout the beginning of college and
there's a point in playing baseball
where you are getting ready for
highschool baseball but you're still
playing like travel baseball so
basically like you're playing in two
different leagues or sort of
simultaneously playing in two different
leagues and the two different leagues
have different rules so one you know one
league has 95 bases one leading foot
they yes you know so you're you're going
back and forth and it's you know the
equipment is different metal bat so that
big barrel bats too small robust yeah so
they came out because they you know they
fit a lot of companies baseball brands
we're figuring a lot of kids were in
this transition period where basically
in high school ball you can use metal
cleats but in travel ball you can't
couldn't necessarily always use metal
cleats so they figured you know instead
of selling two pairs of cleats each kid
let's make these cleats interchangeable
so you literally include a a little
screwdriver and you you each cleat on
the bottom of your shoe you're
unscrewing before each game and screwing
in the metal or the plastic ones
whatever fit for that game or league and
I've never ever played except for maybe
the first time I wore them a game where
every cleat was in there there was
always one [ __ ] missing in my bag or
it can fallen out because Europe I don't
know a 15 year old kid trying to screw
drive your cleats while your teammates
are yelling at you to go get ready and
stretching you're saying I'm building
cleats right now sorry one sec so by the
end of the the you know they its
lifespan it was like a sad pathetic like
half clip with maybe three spikes on it
the rest were gone there was like screws
all over my bag there was this shitty
little screwdriver that was always in my
way uh that was that was horrible
that was because in theory you're like
yeah that's well yeah it sounds like a
great plan yeah but it never ever worked
out and it always came to the point
where I was either losing cleats or you
know sometimes they would fall off
mid-game which was the worst because you
would feel feet
oh sweet you feeling pop right right
imagine like you're getting set in the
box and you feel click what a my cleats
fall off what do you thinking about that
and then you strike on you're like
thanks a lot like Mizuno or whatever the
[ __ ] I only remember what brand it was
that's why do you say that because in my
best purchases i actually wrote
something not like that similar sports
you know and that's one of those things
like in theory it's a very very smart
thing and you're like this is going to
change my life but then and then so you
have the cleats right there [ __ ] they
break off on but then six months later
you're never using plastic cleats ever
so you're like why the [ __ ] tonight I
had no foresight like I just yeah then I
think in my high school we were we only
had plastic cleats and we weren't
allowed to use metal until college
because they they baby s little delicate
girl flowers you know
yeah baseball's all have weird
differences like that yeah I just
remember the first day I put on a pair
of metal cleats and was like my life is
for it oh my god metal plates are the
bastion comparatively oh yeah anyways
you want to keep going yes yeah that
sounds terrible I'm really sorry thank
you that means wanna cry alrighty all
those little cleats falling on my bag
alright my next worst purchase was along
the lines of the the temptu airbrush
okay so makeup done yeah okay so you
remember during a period on YouTube when
no one really knew if beauty bloggers or
vloggers or whatever were being
sponsored yeah they didn't really have
to disclose it and you know there's a
weird time yeah it was a weird time it
was around it was a few years ago but
you would start to notice as a person
that likes watching beauty gurus or
whatever that everybody all at once
would be like Hocking you the same
product and you're like okay something
something's going on here and I don't
like it but I realized that I recognized
that and I still fell for it and I feel
stupid
so again not a [ __ ] cheap purchase it
was like a hundred dollars and it was
one of those oscillating like little
face brush yeah I've seen a billion of
those yeah it was like you know I don't
know like name commercials right
well those are cheap those are what like
you can buy them for like $10 two
payments of $10 no I think there are $10
now or free you know I'm just trying to
get rid of them yeah but they were
expensive when they first came out and
everybody was talking them you like all
this changed my life changed my face and
you know maybe for some people it did
maybe some people still use theirs yeah
but I just remember like putting my soap
on there using a couple times being like
all right this is nice and then I sat
with the sad reality that was am I gonna
use this powered oscillating brush on my
face for the rest of my life really
Jenna but we can still my life has
become now yeah yeah I just got this oh
dude
yeah like the time that I was really
into using Latisse and I was like oh
this is really cool and then I had this
sad honest conversation with myself like
you really bet you're gonna put this on
your eyelashes every day for the rest of
your life
no those realizations are always so
funny because like looking into a
purchase you have these like short
minded like I need this so badly right
now if I have that then maybe everything
would just be a lot better and no it
wasn't I got played brutal oh I would
like to know in the comments though if
you still have one of those oscillating
face brushes
yeah answer that but also list some of
your worst purchases yeah please umm in
college I am NOT gonna say the name of
this brand okay but in college I was you
know I was relatively decent friends
with one of this these kids who started
an underwear company obviously my
allegiance is to me undies now everyone
knows that but yeah it was what you know
in ecology of like friends you make
friends in a way like your you sit
together in two out of the three same
you know lectures or something and you
just over the courses Messer you just
become like class friends with them you
text them about homework and [ __ ] like
that maybe get lunch every once in
awhile so that I had a friend like that
and he started underwear company and you
know I knew about it because I followed
him on social media and I saw he was
always working with it and [ __ ] like
that and then you know I graduated and
we part ways you know not that good of a
friend so we don't talk too much but
like literally recently I was you know
it popped up again in my feed some house
and one of my old friends posted about I
was like
they're doing really well like this
company seems to be like succeeding
they've built the following they have
decent marketing and like the underwear
looks dope right so let's let's try a
pair and this is like really overpriced
underwear I don't know why that it was
like 30 or 40 bucks for a pair of I okay
yeah it was pretty dumb
that hurts my heart yeah but I mean
obviously I didn't buy in college
because that there's no way I could have
done but yeah so I bought a pair and I
was like yeah I mean this would be cool
because if it works out I'll send them a
message to be like hey great job I just
tried your product finally and I bought
it and I wash it once and it ripped from
a wash like the seam from the waistband
just it was like there was a hole and
that nothing had happened oh no I was
like oh [ __ ] the same crap boxers or
boxer briefs memories Wow and it's just
one of those things when I was like all
that like I had seen thousands of
histogram poses from them from
throughout years of following people who
were doing different and I was like you
know what let's give it a try Rick on
the first wash that sucks I'm not gonna
say his name that'd be me
but that's yeah that's just terrible
it's just like I don't know how you
build a product that just well there's
nothing worse than buying a clothing
item that's over $5 that falls apart in
the wash if it's under $5 and you're
like alright yeah I bought this for $3
fine it fell apart in the wash I'm okay
I'm life goes on but $30 is a lot to
fall apart in the wash yeah yeah I
couldn't it was it was a difficult thing
like comprehend why did that happened
underwear to to me is just like so
wonderful that when you're looking
forward to having a pair of underwear
and it's comfortable and you like it and
then it falls apart you're like well
[ __ ] yeah for real yeah should we you
want to go to my next yeah for sure
that's just my that's the sad story of
my sorry my next bad one is a bumble and
bumble dry shampoo dry hair shampoo like
dry shampoo huh you know how much I love
my Drive yes it's what I live on so that
my hair color doesn't look like [ __ ] all
the time my hair doesn't fall out of my
head by washing it all the time
but this was when my hair was like a
between a blonde and a brunette color it
was sort of both yeah and I usually buy
if I can I'll buy a dry shampoo where a
product at the salon because you know it
helps them yeah I just actually learn
that reason yeah and they also you know
can give you a good recommendation yeah
about what to use on your hair and I'm
willing to pay a little bit more for a
better product rather than a cheapo
price I'm really gonna [ __ ] my life up
although I enjoy cheap things you just
have to hunt for you know there's more
trial and error um so I bought this
Bumble and Bumble dry shampoo which came
in like three colours it came in like a
a white or a platinum blonde a blonde
and a brunette so I got the blonde she
was like yeah here you go this one this
one will be fine so it blends in with
your hair color I guess because I have
all my dry shampoos typically don't have
color right or if anything it may be
white and then you brush it out to be
able to see it but it's not part of the
product yeah okay but I have read that
you can get colored dry shampoos if you
had like a bright red that you can get a
red dress I had you know I've never
gotten that far I've always just used
like white or not yeah and so I brought
this blonde dry shampoo home and sprayed
it on my roots like when my hair got
dirty and this [ __ ] was brown
like my whole head was brown like all
around my face was brown like
everything's [ __ ] like this dark
nasty brown that no one's hair color was
gone and it was just terrible and
there's other products too where like if
your roots are coming in you can put
like a powder over it to make it look oh
my god those are the worst terrible it
just seems so counterintuitive like if
someone wanted to color the hair they
would find means that already exist for
that I would you try to throw that into
a product that you're selling that's
different
try shampoo you're shampooing it dry
yeah I mean I think that they just that
they're going for making it look like
two and one your hair what two and one
yeah well yeah or just you know
freshening up your color when it looks
dirty or yeah it was so awful and I wish
that this [ __ ] girl had told me she
was like
here just that's great and I'm like oh
yeah there's nothing worse on someone
just like completely vouches for a [ __ ]
product yeah well I'm sure it's a fine
dry shampoo and I haven't checked back
with their line of dry shampoos because
I you know me even if a drive shampoo
sucks I will use that hold on the
monitors haha that thing had a date with
the garbage and went straight into it
that's crazy was so mad I had to wash my
hair again
which defeats the point of dry shampoo
pissed I'll be [ __ ] pissed right yeah
although you know it is a great purchase
though because we're not we're not
getting there yet
glitter hairspray lose when I was a
go-go dancer we'd use that instead of
body glitter if you just stand in front
of your friend and glitter spray each
other that's a good product it's
incredible it's an incredible useful no
I'll look into that I feel like I could
use a little touch of glitter if you if
you ever want to I'm dead serious though
like if you ever want to be covered in
glitter don't get like a lotion or like
a something like that get glitter
hairspray and then have somebody spray
with it or spray it on yourself okay ten
times better noted I'm actually going to
write down on my notes later this my
next one is very recent actually I you
know when I'm when I'm eating healthy
and I'm doing good with my diet I eat a
lot of chicken like a lot of you know
not and you know it's it's easy
sometimes to cook it in bulk and the
best way to do that is on our grill so
uh you know I don't like to use like Pam
and stuff like that like that artificial
spray to you know smooth out a service
to cook on I hated that stuff so I would
normally just like suck it up and put
the chicken on the grill and then have
to scrape the stuff that's stuck off on
the bottom but then we were at a store
together and I saw this thing and that
was like it's your own spray cancer that
you put your you put your own oil in
olive oil or whatever and then you you
turn it and you just pump it this is
when we bought reason yes oh really it
says oh my god so you pour the oil in
you put the top on it Harry you have to
like pump it a couple times and then you
tighten it and then it's a spray can
with whatever you put in no not at all
so I poured like a whole [ __ ] ton of oil
like we had just got a new bottle and
pour like a good third of it in this
thing and I'm like spraying and
nothing's coming out nothing at all so
I'm like okay maybe I did it wrong and
I'm like oh maybe it pumps because it
this pump actions huh I'm pumping it
like three or four or five 15 times and
then oh okay it feels a little different
like it feels like it's spring loaded
now so I spray it and then it just
drizzles out all over my hand all over
the outside of its like the metallic
case of it so not only did it not work
but now my whole hand is covered in
olive oil and this like thing is covered
in olive oil so I had to wash it off and
we still [ __ ] have it I just haven't
gotten rid of it it's the worst thing
it's just so dysfunctional I'm sorry no
it's fine I didn't even think of kitchen
gadgets I bought remember when I bought
that julienne slicer the like manual one
are you like Jam a zucchini twirl a
little pot around and it just like I
wanted to cry because all I wanted was
like zucchini spaghetti so bad oh man
bad kitchen items are - kitchen items
are really heartbreaking worse I'm sorry
that didn't work no it's okay it's just
like I know out there I don't know yeah
even if I have to get just like an empty
like Windex bottle and then put olive
oil in that [ __ ] like why not do that
you know that the rose water toner you
have so much I bought an out a button
like a bottle like that oh yeah recently
though and this the same thing though
the spray bottle like the actual damn
tried wiping it like you know just stick
it bleeds you know it instead of misting
and like wow yeah it just shoots like a
concentrated but it doesn't have any
chance me why because it's flat yeah
yeah exactly I feel like a little puppy
or like a cat let's try to get off the
table like spraying myself in the face
oh my god to feed someone of having it
so [ __ ] spray bottles are probably
the worst it sucks dude
it's so frustrating I'm sorry I'm sure
you were all hyped up to to like cook
with your coconut oil in a spray well
it's just like so frustrating in the
sense that like you're like you're
really frustrated that you bought that
product and like I don't know like right
now like I'm talking about it and I'm
frustrated and like you guys think about
any problem you have in life it always
starts in your head with like
frustration and anger and stress and
sadness it all starts in your head all
of the emotions beginning your head but
it doesn't have to be that way if you
download the new headspace headspace
calm slash Jenna Julianne right now to
get started in training your mind what
is headspace you might ask it's
meditation made simple it's so you can
meditate and you don't need to go to
yoga
to pay money you know all sorts of crazy
money for yoga classes or get dressed up
you can do it from the power of your own
phone literally anywhere you are anytime
there something called take 10 where you
meditate 10 minutes out of the day and
you can do it for 10 days and it's free
but basically you do it from your phone
you plug in your headphones you can go
into the restroom at work it doesn't
even matter you can meditate from
anywhere and the thing about meditation
is thousands and thousands of years of
tradition and scientific research have
gone into meditation and it has been
proven through years and years of both
of those things that meditation works it
helps focus it helps your feelings and
your relationships and it also helps
decrease stress so right now start
training your mind by going to headspace
calm / gentle and get the app give it a
try do the take 10 which is an
absolutely free way to meditate for
guided for free for 10 days and and be
on your way with - having a strong
amount it's very awesome I actually did
give it a shot before we got on here and
I was like great are you doing well it's
one of those things where it's like
meditation I mean it sounds like oh
meditation yeah boring whatever overdone
but the animations they have and the
voices it's all very nice and it's very
clean
so give that give that a try for sure
and you know meditation is great but
there's also one more thing that's
awesome is a great night's sleep and you
can't do that on some bad sheets
so check out bowl and branch for your
sheets and your blankets and your towel
and your linen needs because they have
it like ah we haven't taken them off we
have taken well so the thing is they
came to us they were like we want to
sponsor the podcast I was like really
like sheets and they were like okay can
we send you something to try out and
then you'll see and we slept on him one
night and we were like why why is it how
does this exist how is it even possible
to be this comfortable I am Telling You
it is the most comfortable material you
could sleep on it just puts every other
sheet you've ever been on to shame and
the great thing about Bolin branch is
they treat their workers more than
fairly so you don't have to feel bad
about your sheets when you buy them you
go to a bowling branch ship it to you
directly and you know what if you try it
out 30 days later you hate it which you
absolutely won't you can get your full
refund which bowling Branch stands for
stuff like that there are great peeps
check
out by going to bowling branch and right
now if you enter Jenna Julian the
product code Jetta Julian at checkout
Poland branch you get 20% off your
entire order not just one item so keep
that in mind give it a shot
thank you responsibility they donate
money too yes yes yeah they goes towards
fighting sex trafficking and human
trafficking it's a very good cause just
check it out Boland branch that's bol el
and branch and enter Jenna Julian at
checkout for 20% off really awesome yeah
thank you to our sponsors thank you
appreciate it
anyway family way um I just did all
Avoyelles pray so you were next home was
right there and my next one was that we
fit games that came out a long time
would remember that they sold it to in
like a yoga mat the video game and the
board the board Oh God and it was so
heavy and like you had to be standing on
it and it was just a miserable thing and
I wanted hating it so much that I just
like sold on Craigslist for I think
maybe five dollars the kid was like does
it work and I'm like yeah can you please
come get it sucks yeah I actually tried
that one time my cousin had it and we
did the ski jump one was the only on
online but like it's you like fall off
of it it's not it's not very functional
like heaviest yeah I didn't feel like I
could ever possibly get a workout but
they had a good thing going with the
little wiimotes why'd you have to go and
[ __ ] up with [ __ ] weird like weird as
[ __ ] and on the topic of sprays I was as
you know as a baseball fan and a
baseball kid I loved hats growing up had
tons of hats and so naturally when I
start to get allowance and I had some
expendable child income I would go to
the hat store a lot to buy hats and you
know that you know at the time they were
like 20 20 25 bucks maybe for a brand
new fitted new era hat and it was like
the dopest thing so you'd save up and
get a hat and I remember one time at
this hat store it's called lids they had
this spray where it's like next to all
the hats but there's a spray it's like
their protective spray and one time I
was like what does this even do they're
like well you spray on your hat and
basically it never gets dirty I'm like
woah woah woah jeanny like calm down
there that's pretty incredible so all
you're seeing is I have to buy this
$6.99 bottle of spray and spray my hat
and then it's never dirty I'm like well
I'm always getting dirty my shits always
getting ruined so [ __ ] it I got it and I
sprayed it all over my hat and literally
nothing changed at all like yeah like I
don't understand what I was buying I
feel the same way about protective spray
for like shoes and stuff I mean maybe I
just bought a really crappy one but like
that that thing got dirty I still have
it yeah like have almost all my hats and
I remember I bought it I was like health
his skin to change the game I'm gonna
have the cleanest hats nope nope not
even close you know I know it's a lot
they just linked right when you're at
the cashier and then you sort of like
shoe or accessory hat store they're just
trying upselling oh yeah they're in the
perfect spot and you're feeling good
about a new hat you want to keep it nice
and pressed really oh you better keep
the fresh horrible um my next one is a
little bit weird but I wrote four worst
purchases let's get weird parakeet mice
dwarf hamsters and goldfish wait why is
a parakeet in there well let me explain
give me a second okay give you a second
because I bought all of those things
from like a you know a Petco or whatever
your pet store sure and as a young
little kid just looking for
companionship it wasn't allowed to have
a dog um I was not prepared for how
short all of those animals were gonna be
alive for yeah and therefore as an adult
I'm not sure that I could ever put
myself through the pain of having a
short-lived pet ever again I feel you
girl it's not that I regretted spending
the money it's that I just wish we had
more time to be friends yeah but a
parakeet parakeet was the worst because
you know goldfish you don't expect to
live forever and also you just flush it
down the toilet man it's like oh never
okay but you don't it's a it's a [ __ ]
okay the bird thing it's like a it's
more of a real thing I had a parakeet I
two parakeets above they obviously died
and then there's like there's like a
dead bird it's like and they're really
sweet and they're you know they can be a
really good friend and I thought that
way about mice and hamster that not all
hamsters the dwarf hamsters I thought
were just they didn't live
is really really hard as a kid to be
like this is my friend now we're friends
and now my friend is dead yeah
but the parakeet really was like the
last one that I could take because they
really they're very little compared to
you just don't live like chirp they sit
on your shoulder sit with you they're
great I love my parakeets I know I did
the burial thing to my mom my mom like
dug little grave out back and made a
little yeah I'm not sure if I bought
because I do like birds really like them
although I imagine with the dogs that
would not work out well um but if I
could I would have a bird I love them
they're so fun like the bigger like son
Conyers like the ones that love being
touched and yelled and like they're
really cool sad I don't think that I
would buy another goldfish dwarf hamster
parakeet
it's too much for my heart to take yeah
you know and I mean for sure I feel you
go ahead what she makes my next one
growing up it was called I play a lot
pickup basketball
it's called never flat basketball you
ever heard of that no it's basically a
basketball and they they said it would
never be flat and they lied sounds like
a challenge
it was flat like you got a flat I made
that basketball ah like the you had this
new like technology where the layers
were made of carbon whatever and like
they're like it's never flat they
literally titled the product never flat
and I don't remember why don't you call
your product that you're just asking for
it well yeah I'm anyone who's it's like
calling the Titanic that this I mean
when you say it's almost just like a
you're asking for is this a challenge
like are you calling this never flat you
really want me to go challenge accepted
but I mean even just normal use didn't
stay full prudence data didn't stay like
a full-blown basketball I even went at
what it was full and you didn't have to
blow it up it didn't feel like a normal
thought wrong forum well my next one is
from when I was a kid my brother and I
loved slap bracelets but they used to
make them with the metal inside okay so
we got snap like slap bracelets and my
brother was all about life doing it as
good as possible and ours were like
getting worn down so you should be a
cloth around a middle bracelet and he
did it and his was wearing down he did
it
hard that it literally just like slashed
his rings yeah well yeah I mean it's not
no but like yeah that must look bad like
if you see this right yeah I don't think
he has the scar it was just like a cut
no yeah even just the cut that's my god
having your wrist is Bria that's brutal
what was a fun happy slap time now just
are not broke equation yeah way too real
another plastic though um do you uh you
want to do the rest years I skipped a
couple sure um thunder shirts for dogs
the anxiety do you know uh yeah and
everyone like on YouTube was like Oh
marbled Kermit's weird and like skittish
get him a thunder shirt marbles is
barking at things he shouldn't bark at
get him a thunder shirt so I'd even I
got them thunder shirts and it turned
them both into just catatonic like they
didn't move
what do my marbles did everything he
would normally do he just like you can't
stifle that boy when he wants to barking
he's gonna bark and permit just stopped
moving like he just got lethargic kids
had Wakita like you know when you put a
shirt on him and he just stands there
yeah it was like that times ten cuz it's
meant to squeeze them and it is their
anxieties so he would just stand there
like how is this helping Kermit oh he
won't be a dog anymore of it and the
last thing I had was the game geometry
wars I'm not sure that we bought that
though how much you bought three dollars
Julien hates that case it's the it's
like you know when you're teaching a dog
a trick you give the [ __ ] dog treats
when he does good yeah we dis Carolee
can't be don't do so good
you get like four hundred five hundred a
thousand [ __ ] points and you're like
holy [ __ ] that was stressful and we did
it and then you're like oh you needed
eleven hundred points to get anything
you need like a million yeah and it was
like [ __ ] dude it's like never rewards
you know people were requesting that we
play that like our twitch stream and it
was just been denied throwing
controllers across enjoyed it yes Julian
so frustrating alright what do some of
your best some of my best okay as a kid
I as many of you know had five siblings
and step-sibling so the house I grew up
in was very nuts and it was like high
energy
was playing everything all the time we
got dance dance revelution the home one
where you can unfold the mat and play it
on your xbox and it changed everything
like we had tournaments we didn't have
to like like you know I imagine for our
parents we were like knowing as [ __ ]
like high energy stairs like it on DDR
you know like tyre sells out and we did
like you would be dripping sweat we
would get competitive it was like we had
the best time that's that's revolution
in our own like room to play I'm sure
they still sell it dance dance
revolution you know you know I'm talking
about right I've literally only ever
played it like that in our case yeah
that's where they mostly play yeah this
one they have it and they have the setup
but yeah I mean it's not as great
because it like the mat moves and stuff
and I was really shitty but it was so
much fun dude that's awesome dance yeah
that was my first good one what's your
first best purchase my first best
purchase is a dog slick car seat
incredible a dog car seat changed my
life changed my life I know well they
make a lot of like cheap ones or smaller
ones I didn't do that I decided to like
spend a little money and get that big
one that's like a turns your whole but
not your whole but like a lot of your
back row yeah into like a couch
essentially for them raised up really
high so they can see out the windows
which is causing a lot of their anxiety
in the car when they can't see out so
once they're up high then they can
finally relax a little bit see what's
going on know where they are
um and you can strap them in there so
they can't crawl around the car and they
can't you know run around do whatever
making me nervous cuz I've tried like
the little just harnessing them to a
seatbelt let that never made me feel
safe yeah and they're always still they
have enough mobility to get his legs
stuck or like try and get in the back
seat yeah this it just it is the best
thing I've ever gotten no I agree at
least in terms what I've experienced it
yeah you strap them in there you can
ride you can get out of the car like you
don't have to worry about them standing
or like you know they're just so good
just ya know
it's a very very smart thing it's very
well made oh yeah because I had to pay
for it yeah then those dog stairs
they're from a website called GW little
and it is now I'm warning you ahead of
time don't tell me it's expensive I know
if they're not cheap they're the dog
seat the dog car seats and those dog
stairs like scalloped cushions stairs
which we have by the bed I bought those
I don't know five years ago something
like that like no wear and tear they're
still as beautiful and perfect district
12 it you can't pay for seat is it pays
for itself yeah seriously for sure what
about you that's the gift that keeps on
giving by the way true yeah when I was a
kid my brother and I played a lot of
wiffle ball and I don't remember how I
found out about but we discovered this
thing called blitz ball which is blitz
with a Z blitz ball and it was this you
know wiffle balls of holes in it but
this was like a solid plastic green ball
but it was like not hexagonal I'd have
like a million sides it was like not
circled had like you know a bunch of
flat sides around it and basically it's
its thing was that you
they were like you had to learn how to
throw it it wasn't like a nothing and
you can throw this thing like really
really fast or like crazy curve balls or
like dipping rate rising fast balls like
things you could never do in well
football like you could do and it was
still just this plastic thing so my
brother and I would go yeah we would go
out front and go to this like garage
down the street and we have practice and
we would throw these like wild curve
balls that were curving around like
poles and it was the funnest funnest
like thing we ever discovered as kids
that's so awesome
yeah it's like a struggle boomerang
that's less dangerous yeah and we I
remember this is dumb and it's kind of
stupid an anecdotal but when we were
buying a second pack I was like Marlon
should we get the smaller or the large
pack because we were already in love
with it and he said are we [ __ ] or
are we high rollers oh my god you
imagine a couple of kids saying each
other die
serious sporting goods are gone like
these [ __ ] kids man
played sports how do you know if there
exists anymore but that's really cool
yeah I've never even heard of that or
I've seen what yeah that sounds fun it
was fun um my next one was fit flops oh
you love your fifth love yeah well cuz I
love flip-flops um but so what is a
fifth love it's just it's a company it's
a brand but when I found them because I
have bad like arches in my feet so I
need good support and flip-flops are
just terrible for your feet as are like
ballet flats even some of the like boots
and stuff I wear like converse to if I
wear them for sure I just can't wear
those flat [ __ ] shoes there's not
good for my feet and so I was looking
around on the internet I found fit flops
and they built the sole of it like a
sneaker so when you're wearing it feels
like a like a really supportive I've
seen it it's very awesome I've you know
bought two pairs in the last six years
and I wear them every summer and called
her I've only gone through two of them
they last a long time and they're like
you can wear them all day so it's like
hot you're walking around doing like
tourist stuff or whatever at the beach
and you can not have to worry about your
feet hurting yeah
those things change my life for sure I
got my mom on them too that's true yeah
my mom has they're great yeah for those
new people who need that too boy foot it
I'm sure they do there's so became not
so comfortable yeah okay I think kind of
talked about this on the podcast before
but again it's baseball related there
was this mask and it was there was
there's two types of masks as a catcher
there was a hockey mask that goes of
your whole head and there's the
two-piece mask where you wear the
backwards hat shell and you put the mask
over the top and I was always obsessed
with the two-piece because I just liked
it better even though it was always
illegal in high school and [ __ ] but I
still loved it and so I bought one and I
loved it it was the best I played in all
my scalp all leagues and everything and
it was just later I just loved it and
then I you know I got enamoured by this
one that Nike made but only gave two
professional catchers like Jorge Posada
added I remember
a Joe Mauer had it like they it was this
titanium version of that which it was
like feather-light but it was made its
way stronger than all the other masks so
it was like it was naturally was the
thing I needed to get because it was
impossible to get you could not get one
like you couldn't buy whenever he still
can't anyway I was on I had scoured the
Internet through craigslist and ebay for
one of those literally scoured the
internet and I was on Craigslist one day
and I found a mask and I was like this
cannot be real I will buy this what is
the price and he was like oh you know
I'll give you the whole set of gear for
which was the brand new Nike gear I was
like oh [ __ ] for like 200 bucks or
whatever so I like forked over the cash
and I bought it and it was like the best
I still have it it's upstairs it was the
best thing I've ever bought gear wise in
baseball you love that thing you're
never getting rid of it ever turns out
the guy I bought it from was a college
catcher at the University of Michigan
and they're sponsored by Nike that here
so they got masks yeah this is so so
cool I had on peyer's catchers every
single game i warden asking me where I
go sorry bro
it's only one yeah I know you love that
[ __ ] thing it's so sick
that's pretty mine was okay my next one
was sports related also so I was a
pitcher in college and softball and I
was burning through my cleats all the
time because in softball you drag your
back toe on the dirt as a pitcher yeah
yeah like on an angle so basically where
your big toe is that part of your cleat
just wears all the way down yeah and
even when we would throw in the morning
and stuff in the gym um the part of my
sneaker would always just yeah basically
rub off and so I didn't know until I got
I think in high school was when I first
found one but it was a shitty one but I
found the great ones in college it's
called I think it's called like a toe
rubber tough toe tough touch I'll tell
ya I think every time I changed my life
changed my life forever and ever and
ever like you just put it on your cleats
on the front of it and it's just this
big dry a piece of rubber which makes it
weird when you're doing everything else
but it makes it so that you don't just
burn through your cleats and it was like
that saved me so much money that was the
best thing I remember this
in speaking of sport things when I was
in high school when I was a diver
and when I first started I didn't have
what they call like a chamois towel so
you you like when you're practicing when
you're doing anything you're literally
just getting in the pool getting out
getting in the pool getting out of the
pool and you're [ __ ] freezing all the
time which is why in like you know fancy
places they have like hot tubs or you go
sand shooting the Olympics are all
sitting in the hot tub you just wait for
hours and it's [ __ ] cold um but
there's this thing called the chamois
towel is just like a little microfiber
towel towel basically and you dry every
part of your body off and you're like a
lot less cold and just much more ready
to do things yeah and once I got one of
those it changed my life was friggin
awesome cuz why first I was like oh I
don't think it's for me I'm there I'm
kind of cold and wet at home that's all
sometimes DEP isn't you squeeze it out
Saul dragon yep exactly
that's great what's your next show I
think I mean that's I I could say more
but huh I have a couple more I wrote my
bike in college oh yeah you love your
bike I bought off eBay and it literally
got me everywhere which was nice um I'll
tell you other one there's a it was a
Fitness related one I still use today
it's called fat gripz oh you love fat
gripz this is basically a giant rubber
sphere that you you can open it up and
like wrap it around a weight like a
dumbbell or barbell on 200 on your side
and basically you're like you're
gripping a very thick material instead
of a small bar so while you're gripping
it whatever you're doing you're doing
curls you know you're doing jealous or
delos or whatever whatever it is you're
doing as long as you're gripping away
you're working your grip and your
forearms so you're simultaneously
getting a form workout throughout the
and it's it's the only Fitness tool like
I've used for years and years and years
it's amazing well I think your forearm
strength went up immensely once you
started using them because then all of a
sudden you could deadlift fun fact in
base in baseball in college there was
like you know your Fitness like [ __ ]
you had your boot camp and then you test
at the end for like pull-ups you test
the beginning it says the 40 your
pull-ups all that stuff so I'm pull-ups
I [ __ ] hit 32 pull-ups in a row yeah
in the test because I had been doing
pull-ups with fat grip
so once I grip the regular thing I was
like oh this is chill I mean I weighed
160 pounds but still you know 30 like it
was it was crazy and I remember like you
get your forms all vascular vascular oh
yeah there's a downside there was one
time when Julian over uses magnets I
mean they'd be massaged all of the knots
out of his forearms and was that was
probably the most pain I've ever seen it
was pretty rough like you were you're
rubbing basically all these knots out of
my forearm with coconut oil like getting
in there and I was like crying
he saw that right yeah so you pay the
price for Beauty strength that is a
bridge a nice product though my next one
was actually coconut oil that's amazing
perfect um makeup wipes I [ __ ] I
don't know what I did before makeup
wipes existed daily contacts changed my
life chromecast changed my life it's
pretty [ __ ] up chromecast changed my
life so that you can watch like YouTube
videos or whatever on your TV which is
cast is a game changer absolutely um and
also in my last I'll make this my life
looks to her um the Turbie towel which I
thought was like a gimmicky stupid
didn't want it those little hair towels
that I have that you put over your wet
hair yeah I use yours I know I used to I
love them I'm never going back to using
a towel and uh the wet brush which is
like a ten dollar stupid brush but it's
essentially made the same as like if you
had hair extensions it's like a really
gentle brush the using wet hair or any
hair it like doesn't tangle like it
doesn't leave hurt your hair it's
[ __ ] amazing and I don't know what I
did before I spent that ten dollars guys
take notes here best inwards worst
purchases we've ever made her that we
can think of yeah that we could think of
yeah I feel like there are more I'm sure
there's so many more yeah maybe we'll do
a part two sometime when we have a
better list another list at least or
maybe you'd combined yeah purchase list
yeah mine just had a lot of beauty fat
beauty mine had a lot of weird baseball
stuffs I have so many sad beauty
products like stumble you have a lot of
beauty products um we were bound to be
sad not every beauty product can be
happy
that's true but you could be happy right
now have you start trading with
headspace yeah Yap check it out and
start doing guided meditation to the
take 10 10 days of free meditation and
see how you like it
headspace calm / Jetta Julian I would
highly recommend giving a try and bowler
bridge give those sheets a try for sure
you get 20% off your order
at bol and branch that's blll and branch
calm and enter Jan Jelena check out
30-day return policy guarantee if you
don't like you send it back thank you to
our sponsors yeah thank you guys and
like we said before let us know in the
comments what you guys have bought your
worst purchases yeah cuz there are
always funny stories with like I know
and I feel like seeing the comments is
really just gonna like jog my memory
yeah I think a hundred percent it is
that you hate cuz I know that there's
been things that I bought that like
Finley to me my god I go every Lane
Jory's that I look like an absolutely I
almost want to text my mom cuz I bet she
knows yeah but yeah let us know thank
you guys for hanging out listening and
watching to see you guys next week in
2016 oh that's crazy
thanks for watching and see you guys in
New Year hi guys
you